souvenez vous souvenez vous il ya
quelques mois je vous en ai un événement
c'était au mois de septembre
je crois que c'est le seul événement que
j'ai pu faire sur des présentations qui
note un peu classique y en avait une
c'était à berlin c'était à elle dans le
cadre de l'ifa hanifa un peu particulier
on vous présentait sa fatigue loyers
bien comme ça là c'est le magic book pro
c'est le dernier ordinateur haut de
gamme de au nord honore madougou produit
[Musique]
il ya quelques mois je pas si vous en
rappelez je devais présenter le magic
bout que j'avais trouvé super
intéressant surtout extrêmement bien
positionnés en termes de tarifs pour moi
la partie design et très bien réussi au
nord a bien bossé sur cette machine est
là ou non est revenu avec une version
professionnelle de son magic book une
version un peu plus musclé plus musclé
que moi vous vous en douterez et qui
surtout permettra d'exprimer votre
créativité on est dans l'idée de la
créativité on lit dans l'idée de la
mobilité pouvoir bosser par tous de
s'exprimer sans aucune limite
sans aucune frontière on va donc
regarder si ce match debout prochain ses
promesses c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui réalisé en partenariat des connor
merci au nord de soutenir la chaîne en
sponsorisant cette vidéo alors regardez
cet ordinateur on va déjà jeté un coup
d'oeil au design global
il ya vraiment un côté très premium dans
cette machine
moi j'aime beaucoup et statique de base
et je vous l'avais dit lorsque j'étais à
berlin que vous l'avez présenter les
haut parleurs qui sont situées sur le
côté vous avez votre bouton pour
l'allumer pour le teint qui sert de
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
mineurs est verrouillé très rapidement
ça c'est cool
vous avez ici une petite webcam qui est
caché dans le clavier c'est pas la
position idéale se faire toujours quand
ses cachets en haut de l'écran parce
qu'ici on vous filme d'en bas et c'est
pascal plus beau néanmoins pour la
confidentialité
ça c'est une super idée un design très
très très bien maîtrisé un clavier qui
est plutôt agréable à utiliser un
trackpad qui même si on aurait pu les
mets un peu plus grand frein très bien à
faire et surtout ici vous avez un très
grand écran de 5,5 pouces full hd 1920
par 1080
c'est une dali ps au niveau de l'espace
colorimétrique on est 100 % srgb honor
maîtrise vraiment bien son écran les
couleurs sont très bonnes les contrastes
sont très justes et l'un des gros points
forts de cet ordinateur qui est vraiment
destiné pour la création pour la
créativité plutôt retouches photos
plutôt graphiste l'anglais
lyon est aussi plutôt bon c'est surtout
un écran qui certifiait tüv rheinland
anti sentiments donc il va venir lutter
contre la fatigue oculaire on a ici un
design qui est minimaliste débord qui
sont vraiment ready sur le côté pour
faire place belle à l'écran en écran qui
occupent 90 % de la face avant
c'est un ultra portable le châssis est
en aluminium il est léger il fait à
peine 1 kg 7
bien que vous ayez d'écran de 7,1 pouces
il tiendra fassi de 15,6 pouces il est
assez compact et vous pouvez l'emmener
facilement partout avec vous deuxième
point positif de cette machine c'est sa
performance
on tourne ici sur un amd reisen 5 4600 h
avec six coeurs et 12 threads vous avez
16 giga de ram c'est la ddr4 et vous
avez 500 12 giga de stockage en ssd pcie
élevé mais c'est un processeur qui est
gravé en 7 nanomètres et qui fera
parfaitement la faire pour toutes vos
retouches de photos sur lightroom mais
également sur photoshop parce que oui si
on a vraiment une machine qui est dédié
à la créativité au nord nous annonce
jusqu'à 11 heures d'autonomie on arrive
à un peu moins de 10 heures 9 heures en
fonction des usages que vous allez avoir
si vous faites on a des programmes un
peu aux gourmands forcément l'autonomie
va diminuer mais sur un usage un peu son
arc contenus multimédias un peu de
retouches navigation sur internet
9 heures vous n'êtes pas mal et en plus
vous le recharger rapidement grâce à cet
accessoire c'est son blog de charge de
65 watts qui vous permet de recharger de
0 à 50 % en seulement 30 minutes
on tourne ici sur windows dix familles
côté connectique on ait une prise usb
c'est hdmi 2.0 on a 3 usb 3.21 qui situe
du côté gauche et deux du côté droit
sans oublier une prise jack 3.5 pour moi
la partie qui est un peu en dessous
c'est lo jo on a des haut parleurs qui
développe un son un peu trop médium
médium grave médiums aigus
on manque de spécialisation on manque
d'amplitude on manque de respiration
mais néanmoins comme je vous le disais
vous avez une prise jack 3.5 donc si
vous souhaitez brancher un casque bien
vous pouvez le faire ça vous augmentera
l'expérience et si vous avez un casque
sans fil et bien vous allez en plus de
bluetooth 5.0 pour venir la paire et
donc ça c'est bien on l'a donc un
ordinateur que je trouve très cool
j'aime beaucoup le design l'écran est
très bien on a de la performance pour
tout ce qui va être création je vous le
dis une fois de plus photoshop lightroom
et compagnie c'est la très bien pour
venir jouer à des jeux
faire du gaming vous avez une machine
qui sera endurant performante
l'autonomie est somme toute correcte le
design est très cool il ya quelques
petits points de détails que gémir
regretté notamment ici au niveau du
trackpad message avait déjà fait
remarquer sur le magic book et c'est
sensiblement la même chose sur magic
groupe professionnel j'aurais aimé un
peu mieux fini un peu plus précis
néanmoins on ne peut pas tout avoir
roulé sur un ordinateur qui coûtent
moins de 1000 euros et qui justement et
en prendre ce moment en période de noël
je vous ai mis le lien en bas dans la
description aller jeter un coup d'oeil
pour vous faire plaisir à notre point de
regretter c'est au niveau de la
connectique vous venir changer votre
ordinateur ici avec de l'usb c'est ce
qui fait que lorsqu'il est branché sur
le secteur et bien vous n'avez plus du
tout 2 ports usb c'est disponible vous
devez vous contenter de ports usb à
c'est un peu dommage vu les standards
actuels j'aurais trouvé ça bien qu' au
moins deux ports usb c est qu on vienne
m'enlever un port usb un autre point
mais c'est vraiment un point de détail
vu qu'on est sur l'ordinateur qui est
vraiment destiné aux créatifs on aurait
pu espérer retrouver un lecteur de
cartes sd ce n'est pas le cas ici mais
ce n'est pas le cas dans beaucoup
d'ordinateurs donc rien de bien grave là
dessus mais il ya également plein
d'autres produits cheonan je vous invite
à les découvrir notamment cette période
de fêtes avec plein de tarif super cool
là j'ai un honneur daffix promet il y en
a plein d'autres des smartphones avec la
galerie vous retrouverez également des
petits écouteurs pour venir faire du
sport il ya également des montres
connectés ça c'est là honorent 25 lits
également là honorent ou hgs pro qui une
monde connecté urbaine également pour le
sport en extérieur et en intérieur avec
un grand écran on n'a plus de sens mode
d'entraînement elle coûte 249 euros 90
mais au nord afrique également des
routeurs vous avez le honor routeur 3
enfin y'a plein de produits super cool
chez au nord je vous ai mis un lien en
bas dans la description pour aller les
découvrir et trouver les produits qui
feront mal votre coeur voyez comme c'est
beau ça un peu bas de votre coeur une
bécane que je trouve cool et qui coûte
normalement 929 l'euro qui est moins
cher actuellement une fois de plus le
lien est dans la description j'aime
beaucoup ce que nous propose au nord sur
ce magic vous projetez mais déjà le
magic vous que je vous ai présenté il ya
quelques mois le magic vous promet une
expérience encore plus haut à un tarif
qui reste très alléchant a vous de me
dire vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire comment vous trouvez ce
macbook pro duo nord est ce que vous
vous êtes déjà laissé tenter est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
est ce que vous êtes un créatif et est
ce que pour vous cette machine pourrait
faire la faire marquer moi tout ça en
bas en commentaire et quand l on
retrouve très rapidement parce qu'on
continue à parler de teck
oui il y en a plein de tous les côtés ça
ne s'arrête pas m'ont beaucoup d'amour a
très vite car
[Musique]